bonjour je m d'allègre remercier d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
au delà de la crise on afghanistan
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
gouvernement grec a proposé une loi
accélérant l'expulsion des migrants
on fait du gouvernement grec comme à peu
près tous beaucoup de pays de l'union
européenne très peur qui lui arrive une
vague comparable à celle de 2015 en
prenant cette fois ci d'afghanistan d'un
autre côté c'est un secret pour personne
que la grèce a beaucoup de mal à gérer
finalement la question des réfugiés et
de surcroît elle a aussi très peur
qu'une fois ces gens soient entrés en
grèce l'europe lui disent qu'elle n'a
qu'à les garder et comme en définitive
elle n'arrive déjà pas à s'occuper
convenablement de ceux qui sont là de
surcroît je veux dire l'immigration en
provenance d'afghanistan n'est pas
nouvelle à l'heure actuelle près de la
moitié des demandeurs d'asile qui sont
en outre bloqués en grèce son cargo
avant même quoi que ce soit avec les
talibans donc c'est vrai que l'opinion
est divisée comme vous l'avez montré
mais dans les endroits dits sensibles il
y à beaucoup plus
de gens je dirais auquel le gouvernement
fait plaisir en construisant un mur pour
éventuellement symboliquement arrêter
des entrées depuis la turquie ou la
turquie construit son mur vous le disiez
à l'instant joël des grues là la grèce a
déjà du mal à gérer
les migrants qui sont déjà sur sur son
sol qu'est ce qui explique cette gestion
compliquée de la grèce
ben apparemment
bon des questions de difficultés de je
dirais inhérentes à la grèce à gérer
tout une question de problèmes
informatiques
d'enregistrement etc et puis le fait que
tous les gens qui se voient refuser
d'asile en définitive elle ne parvient
pas à les renvoyer en turquie où elle ne
parvient à envoyer qu'un tout petit
pourcentage est donc les autres restent
aussi des gens désespérés ils sont en
grèce ils sont illégaux on ne veut pas
les légaliser l'europe ne veux pas les
laisser entrer puis la grèce et toute
façon eu n'ont aucune envie de repartir
dans ce sens inverse alors c'est un
projet de loi bien sûr pour tenter de
dissuader les migrants qui voudraient
venir en grèce est ce que dans les faits
ce projet de loi pourrait réduire
l'arrivée de migrants dans le pays
et je ne crois pas et le projet de loi
fera très plaisir électoralement parlant
à une grande partie de l'opinion
publique mais je vais dire dans la
situation dans laquelle se trouvent les
gens quand on voit ce qu'ils affrontent
pour arriver jusque là je ne pense pas
que un encombrement de plus ou de moins
d'autant plus qu'il ya pas beaucoup de
deux circuits alternatifs possibles
alors selon les ong
selon vous où en est ce que les ong
poursuivront leur mission de sauvetage
parce que c'est aussi les ong 1 qui qui
disent que cette loi va compliquer leur
travail au quotidien
et oui mais je pense que c'est
effectivement un des buts de la loi le
gouvernement a tendance à penser les
opinions aussi d'ailleurs que les que
les ong et finalement parce qu'elles
aident les migrants
contribuent à les encourager et si je
puis dire alors le conseil de l'europe
s'est dit inquiet il quant à cette loi
et appelle à la grèce à respecter les
droits de l'homme est ce que justement
le conseil de l'europe peut mettre un
petit peu son son nez dans les affaires
internes de la grèce et avoir peut-être
un poids sur ce futur projet de loi
je ne suis pas très très convaincu même
de la sincérité du conseil de l'europe
et des institutions européennes dans ce
domaine je veux dire il ya quand même
beaucoup d'états en europe qui sont
ravis puisque on les paye pour ça que
les turcs eux conservent plusieurs
millions de réfugiés dont je veux dire
ces malheureuses personnes ont déjà un
premier obstacle a grandi à franchir que
de plus en plus sérieuses et entrer en
turquie ensuite il faut un deuxième
l'obstacle ses entrées en graisses et en
sel ça pognait sait comment faire pour
arriver en sortir puisqu'en fait leur
désir n'est pas de rester en grèce merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous joël
délèguera je rappelle que vous êtes un
maître de conférences à l'inalco et
spécialiste de la grèce merci beaucoup